và biểu từ của họ báo từ ra ngày 25 năm,
nguy phân mua 1 mong mong mong mong ra i ra ní smero bà kê thằng bình.
Tây ra không a sĩ quá thành đối với tổ tuyền đi qua biệt hông ước,
mà chỉ thu phi cho các sĩ của hàng hai tình thiết.
Theo phi i ra, các quản phi này được sự dụng cho họ đậm giận đường tổ tuyền,
bảo vệ mối trường biển và suy tri ăn nên tại biệt hông ước,
vệng bắt thư và biển ông man.
Tây ra cũng cho biệt về khoa lý ra thông hành hai chứ bố cạnh,
các thằng khu vực ra tăng,
đời họ quy đậm một lực lớn hơn.
Sau khi xung đậm giống Mỹ, suy trào với i ra nùng phát thực của thằng hai,
mà đồng tận tàn của biển hông ước đã bị hạnh trị đánh kể.
I Van hiện yêu cầu nhau tổ thằng mại phải sinh phép,
trước khi đi qua tuyền được biển chiếm lực này.
Chúngy đảo tổng thống mi đường năng trăm tình bố,
Washington muốn bảo đam tự só hàng hai ngoàn toàn tả hông ước,
và phản đối về tuy phi được tổ tuy tế.
Theo dự chức i ra, các quốc trở đồ về niệm đăng tích tổc,
và hai bên này đại được đồng thận được với một số lội giống u立 quan,
để chấm giữ suốt đồ khu vực.
Tuy nhiên các bạn đề thành chốt như trưng trình hạp nhăn,
và giữa bảo trưng phát và ứng tình thử dân đảng phán.